hello and welcome to this video playing
tap y'all off okay what do I do let's go
before I want to mix it up a little bit
play a little bit more than some other
openings um yeah okay I can play the
open I mean I can't not really from
ability but I want to be a little bit
more versatile so this is not the most
aggressive line but I simply the
Yugoslav attack is something something
where I have no idea about so I'm
playing the classic got set up here okay
something like this you should f 1 22
this is something that I feel I can play
without getting a getting checkmated in
short order m95 is that good here I
guess I'll do that okay so he probably
wants to put this night on c5 ok I think
c3 looks like it fits in this position
anyway aha interesting so he's happy to
get his pawn structure destroyed but
he's got open files this is not to be
underestimated hmm interesting 94 is
also a possibility just let's see where
he goes all of the mornin I'm not sure
about yeah yeah thought before it's
quite good I mean of course he I would
like to have the rook back on a one but
it's not a big deal and maybe but should
be 54 strong but ok it doesn't really
matter this is good anyway the aimpoint
is pretty weak
it was a weird decision to take on v3 I
thought 94 was much better yeah brigade
no not much else okay so this should a
six now is a very dry way of doing it
but it doesn't look bad
hmm yeah yeah I'm not sure if I'm i
could go be five it's not completely off
but not ideal now it's a bit not not
ideal hmm that's a good move okay i'm
still I probably have to do it and I
would have to do it but other
continuations look very yum and look
very slow check
okay I don't want to take the six that
looks fishy there are also things
hanging so laughs got 995 will be an
issue a little bit for night p 3 and
this hanging i have ninety-seven but
still there's also things hanging on my
end doesn't feel right what I did to him
somehow it might be might be good though
okay so queen is hanging if i move the
Queen now let's see i can wait to put it
green hang the rooks look I and rooks
are hanging in situ last night a one
tweenty one their screen c4 and I can
take yet should should be good then d6
with temple night a 196
I mean I can also take g7 isn't that
just a piece that's just a piece
actually it's a bit easier to put the
bishop here how to play here night at
five if you take that clean age 5 is
probably no defense to that can also
take the six
we also look T 1 for the backlink mage
maybe let's threaten that night f5 still
threatens the back ring made or the
capture can also take age 5 time morning
and I anyway
the cake screen g3 and that's still made
right check
huh Ok Go kh7 but mm it shouldn't help
it's still a rook black resigns hmm yeah
and I'm really not sure about this b5
business I think a critical moment was
right here see 395 and here well okay i
can i can take that but i wasn't sure
about this kind of structure with black
getting there was open files okay i
think this is let's a play of a move for
sure but now he should go tonight c4 i
think this makes far more sense maybe he
was somehow worried about tactics I
would have just played a normal movie f3
or something like that um on 94 maybe I
don't know maybe what's so great that
this could happen something like this
but there's f 6m that doesn't lead
anywhere and again I can take this for
troops for two points but no no Bishop
b5 seems to be good according to the
engine mmm now I thought about that too
late and this is just losing stuff yeah
can happen throw care to go here and
this is this makes lots of sense Oh II
fire very strong tactical move but stock
fish hmm very nice yeah black cannot
capture check it loses the house your
five is very strong I mean this is oops
not helping because now everything is
crashing down 97 I'm very nice ma'am I
mean okay here I'm strategically better
but
not not the decisive e5 is still very
strong trying to take again you cannot
capture okay I wanted to play
strategically now this young be five
maybe this is too simple okay this
doesn't work okay interesting so the
engine wants to do this oh that's a move
that did not really consider that much
but it is pretty good actually the
bishop is in a tough spot I mean I
should be okay I should be worse but it
wasn't ideal mate did this check yet
yeah i'm i'm clearly better in detail
and this shouldn't work him just wins
the house queen d 695 was also ok check
now and here yeah yeah this is avoiding
the maid but he's a full we look down ok
well thanks for watching